yes Mr Cameron all these questions are
being asked have a moral dimension and
you keep answering them in terms of
economics
I'd like you to engage a little bit more
with the mold I mentioned that these
questions arise to me helping someone to
get a job has a moral dimension it gives
them the dignity and pride that comes
with work helpings I'm going to get an
apprenticeship that has a moral
dimension it gives someone the chance of
a career and success building a house
that a young family can afford to buy
and own that's got a moral dimension
because it gives them a stake in the
country they live in that's the country
I want to build these plans I've got for
the next five years about taking this
economic foundation that we built these
last five years all the shared sacrifice
that we've been through but not putting
that to waste but saying let's now turn
that into jobs into pay into houses into
good school places and yes also into
that sense at the end of your life that
this is a country where if you work hard
you save and you do the right thing you
should get that dignity and security in
retirement that I think is the right of
everyone who lives in our country